it's not about time it's about the time  that you allocate and the value exchange  right on the way here after I landed I  had about 13 minutes and I tweeted out  to my audience tweet me your phone  number and I'll call you and so a bunch  of people did not worrying about privacy  right putting out their number and I  called eleven people by the time I got  to Chase for breakfast and then I was  you know when I got here as I was  getting ready for a shower because I  needed the shower I just quickly checked  all my tweets and one guy said some guy  tweeted and said you know you didn't  take care of you a lot of time but now I  am an advocate for the rest of my life  and I that phone call cost me I don't  know 39 seconds right so you can make a  lot of impact with a short period of  time you can do nothing for a with a  long period of time there's people that  live their whole lives without making  any impact right let me also call  something out